yay yay yay yay hey you guys I'm so so
excited right now
um ignored this terribleness happening
behind you um I just went to my PO Box
and you guys you send me mad and I'm so
excited that I want to make a video
opening the mail so you guys can see me
go hello every time I hope it's
something and I think I'm gonna put this
on to my other YouTube channel that I
have got who knew this day would ever
come when I'm like a male blog and I'm
gonna put it up on my second youtube
channel I'm an [ __ ]
so this is gonna be a totally unedited
and probably very long um vlog so feel
free to leave at any time use the
bathroom get a drink I'm drinking iced
coffee with whipped cream can you do
that with iced coffee
I don't know but guess who's doing it oh
this girl let's open mail mmm it's
really good
you should put whipped cream on your ice
coffee okay I'm just gonna start the
first one Jenny O'Neill from Springfield
Pennsylvania my cousins live in Scranton
Pennsylvania are they close to each
other this is papyrus this is very nice
paper stock thank you already oh my gosh
dear grace first I like your style huh
hey girl hey girl you're hilarious and
so fun to watch I love your new bangs
all the things they're they're terrible
accessory to have for me so they're
growing out thanks for reading this
letter and I hope you have a great day
your videos make me so happy grace face
PS I think it's gifs oh I still think
it's gifts thank you for this Jenny this
is so sweet oh my gosh I'm already so
excited Paige
Catalano from but Mattituck New York who
a Mattituck oh and it's like a tiny
little paper in a big envelope
I like that
and you taped it I always tape my
envelopes too because I'm always afraid
that there's gonna be a sneaky little
postman that wants to reach the bills
that I'm sending out what is this oh my
gosh it's paper and it's folded wow
there's so many things happening like
this there's a picture oh my gosh you
don't fail at drawing this is so nice
and there's a unicorn and then there's
you and you are so sexy you are
look at those that is so cool
stickers ah Oh II thinks that we should
be best friends forever I couldn't agree
with you more but don't die because just
don't do that oh okay this is getting
morbid isn't it fun to watch someone
read something inside their heads hey
yuge Catalina PS I know I'm creepy and
yes you should write back to it you
won't I probably won't but this is sort
of like writing back so thank you this
is cool
I like this paper stock as well oh my
gosh oh my gosh I'm so overwhelmed right
now Katie one row from excel source C or
Minnesota exosphere some so um powerful
and like oh you two stamps hey why not
because this is America consumerism go
it's a little fish look at the little
fish and then it's squishy
oh I break it no and I think it goes on
the end of a pencil mmm I'll take your
pencils but you wrote her oh my gosh she
wrote a letter on paper Oh Katie one row
enjoy my Blowfish Steve oh it's a
Blowfish and if so she's then what what
is bloody little fish um
oh she says on Mondays I should review
my fan mail sake well Katie that's a
great idea but I'm doing it in this
video here um you're a genius for and
you didn't spell genius right but that's
okay and you made a note that says I
don't know how to spell but you're
self-aware and I don't know how to spell
either that's why I have a hard time
writing handwritten letters because
there's no little red line that comes up
and tells me you did it wrong
Oh your family likes funfetti brownie is
it so great you make fun Betty pancakes
holy F that sounds like a delicious idea
oh you're beautiful thank you so much
for this letter I would not finish
reading the whole thing later I promise
I'm just like um I'm trying to make it
somewhat entertaining for you guys I'm
gonna drink more coffee right now oh my
gosh so good and this is so good Riley
mahom from Fairfax Virginia oh my gosh
Virginia that's a state I've been to
blame Park Virginia is that where they
have the historical bonus burger or
something my mom loves that [ __ ] and I
can't take it
oh oh oh there's something in here
Grayson right oh my god you photoshopped
yourself shooting on the car but oh my
god that is effing awesome Riley Mahan
and you're doing it very well you must
do yoga oh and you wrote a note too oh
and you've got boy penmanship this is
such boy come unticked
oh you made this cool shooting picture
that's so great if you want to check out
Roundy's website it's Riley Mahan calm
oh no no it's not it's Riley month on
down weebly.com I think our use of a
Weebly site for a second obviously said
geo city site and if he's at the Riley
man on Twitter thanks Riley I will read
this later I promise I'm just um you
know I'm gonna keep saying that over and
over this is from what the f
Amata ex-slave hmm from frita colorado
oh I want to give your address out that
would be silly of me huh um so I don't
know if that's a username reflects like
some sort of traditional family name if
it's a user name all right if it's a
sort of additional family name what
though what what okay what is going on
please send an extra large shirt it
biggest weight you can't order a shirt
oh because you don't know oh my gosh you
give me money in the responsibility of
ordering your shirts oh this is so much
oh my gosh okay I will order you a shirt
um I will I will I will try to a Montag
slave is it because you can't use a
credit card you can't you don't have a
credit card to use oh my gosh oh my gosh
I'm overwhelmed right now okay I will I
will send you a shirt I'm not gonna
please don't send me money in the mail
that's oh don't send me money
oh my goodness okay let's just move on
Christian Taylor from Killeen Texas
Texas you eat meat down there a lot of
it right I'll barbecue
you're not business funny apart that's
like the same stance oh my gosh
oh you drew things holy crap I'm so
excited oh my gosh
you'd your hands sending mail to each
other
I feel dreadfully spiffy is a lobster oh
saying I feel dreadfully spiffy and a
submarine Abraham Lincoln and a baby and
it's a lazy baby oh and then there's
your perhaps Yiddish friend ah this is
like the greatest picture letter of all
time and I will read it oh what's on the
back a computer that does not compute
mark We Need to Talk you know I
right does not compute how could you say
that mark how oh man this is why I'm not
gonna get married ever huh
this is great mark thank you no your
name is Christian Thank You Christian
for this letter that's really cool of
you what else is there there's this it
doesn't have a name up which from it's a
mystery I hope it's not anthrax tonight
that would be so bad oh oh it's a card i
Crockett you only because you fit so
nicely into your skin huh look at that
creepy like she's so scary
ah Katie it's a woman named Katie yeah
she said check out this card I was going
for the perfect balance between sweet
complimentary text and bizarre creepy
picture
you nailed this this is amazing thank
you for this Katie I will read this I
promise I promise I will read this I
need to organize things better okay this
is from Morgan Cooper's Cooper's that's
such a cute funny last name from San
Diego California great burritos in San
Diego's probably the best burrito
remember eaten was in San Diego and I
plan on doing more in my lifetime
open this oh I feel like I'm in high
school and you know how you guys send
all those letters to each other well I
guess you guys sound like talking text
message to each other now when I was in
high school we didn't have cell phones
and we would send letters and it would
say right back at ya WB grace Helbig
what's up the first time are you drew me
that is me that is me you are being an
artist I give you five stars I would
give you four if you didn't like Bailey
so much oh that's so sweet oh you bet
you got haste and I called you Morgan
Booker's your last name kuipers is like
really cute I went to high school with a
guy named Terry Hubert so there's that
oh my gosh shirt is this from it's no
name on it but it's a shoebox Hallmark
card Oh someone
going all out it's it butt-naked or buck
naked look at these old women age-old
question ha oh my gosh it is a picture
yes Jen this is Jen her friend and ELISA
and her huge fans Jennifer Gilbert and I
think this is her graduation picture
that's the greatest graduation picture
of all time oh it's so great
thumbs up for you my stupid graduation
pictures like me like this holding a
rose and it's so stupid and I hate it is
this are you graduating high school or
college senior high school this is great
thank you for this Jen until Annalise I
said hey girl shoebox okay oh my gosh
don't fall
oh it's um fell okay huh who's next
great huh love it whoever stickers the
stickers on it holy crap from Joel Allen
in Australia home like is that why it's
shaped like this cuz you guys are weird
down there um just kidding you're not
weird kind of might get this open myself
we're gonna you taped this so well that
I can't open it without potentially
ruining it I'll go open it from this end
but it says oh my god
sending some Daily Grace love from Down
Under it's a giraffe it's a friggin trap
and it's holding a cupcake and this is
what's a person inside you see the
cupcake holy I'm gonna can sit up on
your desk
Oh Joel thank you so much thank you so I
always feel like I look kind of like a
giraffe yeah I mean you see it do you
guys see it okay what's next
Megan Whitman head girlfriend from
Shawnee Kansas oh this is Shani in New
Jersey and they were always very good at
tennis let's see oh it's a pretty
looking at Paisley whoo flowers Jer
grace first of all hi how are you I'm
well thank you
how's their family they're good good
that's nice
it is I want to write and tell you how
awesome you are
ah you rule I love to hear back from you
this is your hair back to me right now
thank you for sending this letter I will
read it I just don't mean oh and you
wrote her back too uh thank you you have
six pack abs now from laughing think
yeah you know I should start my own
workout program no I shouldn't
okay who's this fun Carly Meyers from
Harrisburg Pennsylvania I think I've
been in Harrisburg Pennsylvania or I
have it but sounds nice yes okay great
you have really nice penmanship cardille
of admirers oh you made fun Philly
brownies yeah yeah good for you they
were delicious and you got a bunch of
your friends to start watching you just
roll it your family's coming to New York
soon great come see a show at the
people's Improv Theater or Wednesday
night at nine o'clock it's free come
check it out Thank You Carly I will read
this I need not keep saying that and
someone sent me an office depot catalog
who sent me this david pranks or no this
was probably supposed to go to david
breaks in brooklyn but i got it
anyone need some pants look at all these
for me okay this big one from one old
Ferry Road cook something University
what is that the University think this
is gonna be fun I'm breaking it oh my
gosh
grace watching down the grace that work
makes it less boring you sent me at
Roger Williams University kit
application kit I can apply up there
academic calendar this is so great
I know what they're doing all the time
oh I can get a room with a view and more
this guy is obviously walking for more
he wants more look at that there's foam
my gosh and it's there a map of the
campus
brystol discover the secret discover the
charm nope discover the country you guys
love to be discovered finite to the
future make it happen
oh man thank you so much for this this
is really very nice who sent this to me
is our name on it
what you cook is this where you work do
you work it Roger Williams University
where I would sit Rhode Island whoo ooh
and then Joe thank you for this whoever
send this to me
thank you I last but not least oh man
people said crazy things let's do it um
this is from amber bowels ha too easy
from Cleveland Mississippi Missouri puts
which ones MS and it's fragile oh my god
do not bend oh my god this is so
exciting I will try not to bend it let's
go
Hulk okay oh my gosh it's a it's a it's
a ho my sickles holy look are you do you
see this with your eyes because this is
insane oh my god oh my god
grace I love your shows my whip and I
watch every day no you look better so I
hope you like this whorehouse aw
Bailey's big campaign for you amber
amber you are incredible awesome amber
should be your doctor tips this is so
great thank you so much for this I love
Andy Warhol how did you know this I my
mouth is not making senses thank you
this is so cool of you holy crap okay
last but not least Kathleen
may L from Mount Vernon New York don't
burn it up too like I've been there that
sounds like a fun place I think it cooks
people from my college or from Merrill
Vernon or they're just from Vernon
they're separate Vernon and Mount Vernon
we're burning a new comer tonight a new
jersey
this is [ __ ] of bat [ __ ] about happen
inside my head oh my god what's
happening oh my god what the crap is
this a bag oh my and it's got oh it's a
baby bag and it's got Care Bears on it
oh my god you said me a baby bag holy
and you sent me up a photo album oh my
god this is so nice of you oh holy crap
and you send me a hair clip
Oh a Hello Kitty hair clip hello kitty
this is my hours put myself in the head
look it's beautiful oh my god holy crap
I will use this I will use this Thank
You Kathleen may l that was amazing
thank you to everyone that said things I
feel like really too special you made me
feel too special to special and I don't
know what to do with it thank you guys
so much I think I'm gonna try and check
this pit box I can't even make sentences
because I'm just I'm overwhelmed by
everything right now but thank you guys
I think we're trying to check the peel
box it for once a week and then make one
of these if it I can't make work thank
you guys so much
my voice has gone up like four octaves
in this video and they don't know how to
end it
other than say thank you thank you thank
you you guys are sweet little [ __ ] oh
one sensor don't like bye